con el 85% de los votos escrutados se
consolida la ventaja para benjamines
tañaju y sus aliados el bloque que se
conformaría junto al extrema derecha y
los partidos Ultra ortodoxos de momento
el recuento le da 65 escaños a estos
bloques una cifra que puede cambiar Con
lo poco que queda por por explotar por
un lado hay dos partidos el que están
luchando por cruzar el umbral uno hacia
la izquierda que está rozando es umbral
y posiblemente pueda terminar accediendo
a la knset pero también se necesitaría
para cambiar la para revertir la
victoria de netaniaco que el partido
árabe también cruzará ese umbral una
misión un poco más complicada estos
pequeños partidos se vieron afectados
por una alta tasa de participación que
estuvo en el 71,3% la más alta desde
2015 y que terminó siendo un dato
favorable para netaniaju una vez de que
se consoliden los resultados que se
conozcan las cifras oficiales entreguen
al presidente Isaac él deberá dar el
mandato en este caso si es en España
justo confirmado para formar un nuevo
gobierno y allí tendrá 42 días para
negociar entre otras cosas los
ministerios y el reparto con sus aliados
por ejemplo uno de los que se espera es
ver si y tamar benguir el
ultraderechista racista y anti árabe
termina ocupando el Ministerio de
seguridad interior un cargo sensible
dentro del gobierno israelí ahora
Federico Cuáles son los desafíos que se
plantean para un evento al gobierno de
beñamine tallao y también la extrema
derecha
al margen del alto costo de vida que es
el principal de la principal
preocupación de los israelíes también
hay un cierto desafío de cómo puede
resentir esto las relaciones exteriores
senadores de Estados Unidos antes de las
elecciones expresaron su preocupación
por la inclusión de la extrema derecha
en un eventual gobierno de netanaku por
otro lado el leche de Primer Ministro ya
se ha mostrado en contra por ejemplo del
último acuerdo marítimo firmado entre
Israel y Líbano anticipó que buscaría
una manera de neutralizarlo sin
especificar como Aunque hoy desde el
Líbano dijeron que ese peligro es que
ese de acuerdo no corre peligro Otro
aspecto a tener en cuenta ese de cómo
evolucionará el juicio por corrupción
contradetañaju sus aliados nacionismo
religiosos del extrema derecha están
buscando una reforma judicial que podría
beneficiar retroactivamente al caso de
netaniaco aunque él negó que vaya a
promover ese tipo de proyectos de ley y
por último será como se aborda el
conflicto palestino israelí y la
violencia
y Jordania que es la más alta desde 2015
sobre todo teniendo en cuenta Un
gobierno mucho más extremista que
obviamente dejaría fuera de la mesa de
cualquier prospecto de diálogos de paz
pero aparte por ejemplo y por mencionar
lo que dijo ven Giving anoche pretende
esta fuerza accionismo religioso en
descolonizar lo que se traduce en
anexionar por completo los territorios
palestinos ocupados lo cual Obviamente
generaría si se Avanza en ese sentido
una atención todavía mucho más al